[Musique]
c'est un bâtiment de béton et de rouille
une épave qui depuis 25 ans menace toute
l'europe
aujourd'hui encore le réacteur numéro 4
de tchernobyl est un danger à
l'intérieur de 100 tonnes d'uranium
fondu un magma extrêmement radioactif
dont personne ne sait quoi faire
et pourtant depuis quelques mois il y à
de nouveaux visiteurs sur le site
[Musique]
maintenant nous sommes très proches du
réacteur nucléaire de tchernobyl
donc nous allons nous arrêter devant
pour faire des photos depuis le 1er
janvier 2011 les autorités ukrainiennes
ont officiellement ouvert la zone de
tchernobyl au tourisme désormais le
réacteur est photographié comme la tour
eiffel où la statue de la liberté nous
pensons que c'est un héritage important
pour l'humanité c'est important pour
l'humanité c'est quelque chose qui ne
peut pas être pardonné ou enfin oublier
oublier oublier pardonner non plus sur
le site ce jour là un groupe de français
ils sont membres d'une association
humanitaire qui vient en aide aux
enfants irradiés de tchernobyl
c'est des gens si la tension qui sont
restés c'est impressionnant
c'est pas spécialement un plaisir de
venir ici honnêtement ne voir sur des
photos c'est bien mais
c'est partager quelques chaussée
justement partagé le fake party super
leur douleur et
ils sont restés jusqu'à combien de temps
on va venir on reste un quart d'heure et
en sons rock au cours de la nuit ici ça
dépend dans quel but
elle n'a bien les tories et pas des
petits jacquet l'esprit de tourisme qui
sont ces touristes des temps modernes
venus visiter les vestiges d'une
catastrophe nucléaire
quels risques prend-il a passé plusieurs
heures sur ses terres irradiées et que
reste-t-il avoir 25 ans après sur le
site du plus grave accident
technologique de l'histoire de
l'humanité voyage guidé dans la zone
interdite de tchernobyl
[Musique]
retour en france où la grisaille du mois
d'avril vent qui souffle bateaux au
mouillage ce jour là la seyne sur mer
affiche une triste mine
il est temps de plier bagage le réacteur
de tchernobyl a explosé en 1986 à cette
date maxime n'était pas né pourtant
demain avec quatre amis il part en
ukraine pour un voyage qu'il s'est un
peu particulier
[Musique]
j'ai pas le montrer à mes camarades de
voyage parce que ils vont se foutent un
peu de ma gueule d'ange 1
je prends des anxiolytiques mais ça
serait pour l'avion mais je vais prendre
quand même petit masque moi je me dis
toujours il vaut mieux il faut que je
suis intelligent que les autres je
puisse protéger c'est mieux à la limite
la valise carmody l'avait différente des
autres voyages en ce sens vous avez des
vêtements que vous aller balancer parce
qu'il y aura des particules hautement
radioactives dessus
donc voilà
a tchernobyl la radioactivité est en
moyenne 35 fois supérieur à la normale
rien de dangereux pour la santé
promettent les autorités mais maxime à
la veille du départ préfère quand même
consulté un médecin généraliste est donc
ogier howard pas ce que je vais faire un
voyage en ukraine
comme j'ai un collègue qui sur internet
il a dit qu'il allait voir son médecin
pour lui faire prescrire de l'iodé lui
demander son avis alors j'avoue je fais
pareil
effectivement effectivement on prescrit
de l'yonne en cas d'irradiation
est-ce que ça a un intérêt en préventive
si tu as dans une zone qui a été irradié
très honnêtement je sais pas un peu
dépassé le médecin va appeler une
pharmacienne elle lui répond quelques
minutes plus tard en france les
comprimés diodes sont distribués sur
ordre des préfets mais le médecin ne
s'avouent pas vaincus il propose un
drôle de médicaments
alors le sel tu peux acheter du sel en
piano donc pourquoi pas du sel de table
contre les radiations
nous avons vérifié totalement inefficace
[Musique]
mais maxime devra s'en contenter
je n'hésiterai pas à manger salle le
show a carrément dans la bouche et son
voyage lui réserve bien d'autres
surprises
quatre heures d'avion plus tard à 2000
kilomètres de la france kiev la capitale
de l'ukraine
première étape du voyage maxime vient
d'arriver avec quatre compagnons moyenne
d'âge 26 ans
ils sont agents du trésor public
enseignants conducteurs de trains
statisticiens et pizzaïolo
ils se connaissent depuis le collège
mais c'est leur premier voyage ensemble
loin de chez eux et à la veille de la
visite
aurélien valentin aymeric cola et maxime
ont chacun une raison différente d'être
là il était allé voir d'aller dans un ex
pays socialistes et voir justement là le
côté ravagé est tout aussi c'est les
deux choses qui me plaisent et c'est sur
ce sens ma motivation
colas le prof et surtout venus pour
s'informer sur les dangers du nucléaire
bonnet ainsi sébastien africa star était
beaucoup moins gras évidemment il y
avait vu sur quelques petits rouges est
une autre
avec un accent d'hier voir les
conséquences
ça me paraît quelque chose
d'important
pour
valentin lui se considère presque comme
un pionnier
parce que je crois c'est que les com
pour votre fils les premiers qui sont
allés visiter les camps lorsque ça a été
permis d'aller s'était étonnée je pense
que ça peut être très bien perçu
comme lui aujourd'hui
bien sûr l'histoire le communisme et les
débats sur le nucléaire tiendrons nos
cinq amis éveillé une partie de la
soirée
[Musique]
le lendemain une cinquantaine de
touristes est au rendez vous
[Musique]
mais attendent un peu en fait à ce que
du monde parce que c'est maintenant
c'est officiel on peut y aller à turin
mobile donc je pensais le début c'est
ouais je m'attendais à ce qu'un peu de
monde mais j'avais vu sur le site qui
avait pas mal de nationalités qui se
rendait à tchernobyl ce jour-là tarif de
la visite 115 euros par personne
depuis que la zone de tchernobyl a été
ouverte aux touristes ils sont 1600 à
avoir acheté leurs billes
[Musique]
nous venons du danemark et nous étions
fascinés par tchernobyl
nous avons lu sur le journal que nous
pouvions désormais venir et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes là je suis de tomsk
en russie
je viens de sibérie je ressentais le
besoin de venir ici tout le monde se
demande pourquoi je viens là mais vous
savez pour moi c'est très intéressant
c'est une sorte de machine à remonter
dans le temps machine vous râlez dans le
passé 25 ans l'arrière en fait avant de
partir colas dégaine un petit objet son
compteur geiger
alors de là il nous donne une valeur qui
est là
alors c'est la quantité de radiations
dans un temps donné
le compteur indique pour le moment 0 2
microsievert par heure
la même mesure qu'en france mais ici le
chiffre va continuer de grimper 0,24 de
micro ce cirque
oui bah c'est un peu plus élevé qu'en
france mais mais bon ça reste assez la
crs ne forcez fut 0,24 c'est
effectivement encore peu c'est à partir
de 1000 microsieverts par an que pour
l'homme
le risque de développer un cancer
augmente
départ pour tchernobyl il y à 120 km à
parcourir pendant le trajet les
touristes ont droit à une petite vidéo
elle montre des sites que les visiteurs
ne pourront pas voir la radioactivité y
est beaucoup trop élevé ces zones-là
reste interdite
au fond du bus les jeunes français
guette le moment où le compteur geiger
va s'emballer pour toujours rien
partout en ce beau combat ça pour chaque
la centrale à 100 m
varela famille franchement si on n'est
même pas un mot millisieverts par heure
moi je peux pas
11h30 premier arrêt le barrage de 10 kg
acquis c'est l'entrée de la zone des 30
km qui ceinture la centrale depuis
l'accident avant l'ouverture au tourisme
c'est ici que la route s'arrêtait la
barrière de sécurité est encore gardée
militairement les trèfles le rouge donne
l'alertent et le contrôle des passeports
et minutieux france 543 c'est bon le
numéro 37
c'est bon je vérifie avec mes numéros et
je reviens aujourd'hui l'accès est libre
personne n'est refusé à condition
d'avoir plus de 18 ans et de s'être
enregistré plusieurs jours à l'avance et
d'avoir payé son billet
ça c'est le genre de photo devant les
panneaux je mets sur mon facebook
c'est vraiment un type il y a personne
d'autre qui fait ça donc vraiment
vraiment monde se prend en photo devant
le l'espèce de des guides des bises en
inde
moi j'aurais nucléaire à quelques mètres
du barrage une vierge un peu délaissé
rend hommage aux soldats qui sont morts
en travaillant sur le site irradiés un
monument qui attire l'attention de tatts
ou quelques mois après fukushima ce
japonais vient ici en quête
d'informations le gouvernement essaye de
cacher beaucoup de choses à propos du
danger les radiations nucléaires
il y a quelques mois
le gouvernement japonais a même annoncé
que tchernobyl n'avait pas tuer tant de
gens que cela ils ont dit que c'était
triste que des gens soient morts lors de
l'accident mais qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment eu de problème majeur par la
suite
donc j'ai décidé de venir ici est
d'essayer de voir et de ressentir ce
qu'il se passe ici
je veux être un témoin de cette
situation witness batteur 10,6
les formalités terminées le bus peut
entrer dans la zone
tout autour de nous un monde irradiés
les deux cent cinquante mille personnes
qui vivaient ici ont été déplacées
abandonnant leur vie leur maison à tout
jamais il ne reste que des ruines
là on passe par une ancienne ville ça
c'était la rue tu vois dans la forêt on
voit encore les maisons
mais un peu plus loin le bus s'approche
d'une bourgade tient mobile
je comprends
à moins de 18 kilomètres de la centrale
nucléaire voici tchernobyl city une
vraie ville avec de vrais habitants
je suis
c'est des plantes vertes et bte
ouvrier scientifique personnel
administratif
tous travaillent sur le chantier de la
centrale ils sont environ 3000 il ne
séjournent dans la zone interdite que
deux semaines par mois
le reste du temps ils ont pour
obligation de quitter cet endroit pour
limiter leur exposition à la
radioactivité
il ya pas mal de bâtiments abandonnés
mais y'en a qu'on verra d'être habité
aussi
c'est particulier comme
passe à 13 heures
nous nous arrêtons devant les bureaux de
tchernobyl une terrine forme celle
agence d'état qui possède le monopole de
l'organisation des visites touristiques
arif remonte si on peut excéder les 30
ans de voltaire notre guide est donc un
fonctionnaire jour je m'appelle youri je
serai votre guise dans la zone interdite
nous avons tous je vous invite à venir
dans nos bureaux aller allons-y
les cinq français posent le pied sur le
sol de tchernobyl et sont directement
conduit dans un local de lagence nous
découvrons qu avant d'explorer la zone
les touristes vont devoir signer un
document
ne pas fumer ne pas manger ne pas
toucher la végétation ne rien ramasser
portait un pantalon et des chaussures
fermées
pas vraiment rassurant le danger ici
c'est la poussière
les radionucléides peuvent s'y cacher
s'il ya de la poussière sur tes doigts
et tu touches la bouche tu pourrais en
inhalé et ça c'est mauvais bon peut-être
pour gagner du temps quelqu'un
pourrait-il lire à voix haute toute ses
règles pour que ce soit plus facile que
tout le monde puisse signer mais on est
d'accord c'est mieux signer de pâlir un
cola n'aura pas le temps de lire le
document jusqu'au bout pourtant les
dernières lignes sont les plus
importantes
l'administration --l'agence tchernobyl
une terrine forme ne pourront pas être
tenus responsables d'éventuels problèmes
de santé consécutifs à la visite de la
zone interdite
en fait ce document signé à la va vite
n'est rien de moins qu'une des chats je
préférerais ne pas signer ce document
les précautions juridiques prises par
les autorités ukrainiennes
que faut-il en penser visitez tchernobyl
serait il finalement dangereux
[Musique]
à kiev nous sommes allés au ministère du
tourisme pour poser la question nous
sommes reçus par le vice secrétaire
d'état dmitri zaruba sa réponse était
étonnante zonage en attaque
si on suit le parcours défini pour la
visite n'est pas dangereuse
il y a des règles par exemple passer
sous un portique de contrôle de la
radiation à la sortie de la zone
mais vous savez dans le réacteur de
tchernobyl il ya toujours du combustible
radioactif qui peut s'avérer être une
source de risque
nous lui montrons les images des
touristes qui n'ont pas le temps de lire
le document
le responsable reconnaît les failles de
l'organisation vous me donner une
information intéressante que je
transmettrai aux dirigeants il faut que
les touristes soient correctement
informés des conditions de visite de la
zone avant de rentrer et les visites
c'est quelque chose de nouveau
nous en sommes aux balbutiements
retour sur le chip de tchernobyl où la
visite a commencé sur votre droite un
monument en hommage aux pompiers
il ya déjà du monde donc on reviendra
plus tard
en fait le bus ne reviendra pas pas un
mot donc sur les 28 pompiers morts aux
premiers jours de la catastrophe
pas un mot non plus sur les cent mille
liquidateur qui ont perdu la vie en
intervenant sur le nettoyage du site
l' agence qui organise la visite évoque
très peu le bilan humain de l'accident
l'idée c'est plutôt de faire crépiter
les dosimètres
alors maintenant nous pénétrons dans la
zone des 10 km autour du réacteur et les
endroits dangereux où il ya le plus de
radiations sont tous concentrés dans
cette zone est ici la vie a complètement
disparu les villages irradiés ont tous
été enterré il y avait autrefois un mot
de 1000 habitants
coop achi il n'en reste quasiment rien
allongée si vous avez peur vous pouvez
rester dans le bus
le guide conduit les visiteurs à
l'intérieur d'une petite forêt au bout
du chemin le squelette d'une crèche
encore contaminé micro
maxime a oublié son masque de protection
à l'hôtel il reste le tétaniser sur le
bord du chemin
mais à ce stade de la visite un bout de
tissu aurait-il fait la différence
votre à 3 ou 4 way ou deux on est en
état plus peur colas lui compteur geiger
en main oscille entre l'inquiétude est
l'obsession de voir monter le niveau des
radiations
c'est un peu moins savoir ne risque pas
c'est pas la peine serait ce que par les
voilà le guide lui déniche facilement
les bons endroits
le compteur ici affiche près de 6
microsieverts ici c'est l'endroit où
s'est écoulé l'eau qui elle avait toute
la poussière du toit à peu près 50 % des
touristes visitent cet endroit pour se
faire peur pour ressentir une montée
d'adrénaline
c'est pour ça que ça leur plaît nous on
n'aime pas tous mais bon ceci dit c'est
pas dangereux pour les gens ce qu'ils
veulent rester dans le bus nous nous
montrons les meilleurs endroits
enfin je veux dire les endroits les plus
contaminés parmi les cinq amis il y en a
un que les radiations et frais
c'est ce qui sortira pas tout c'est
aymeric qui n'a pas bouger de son
fauteuil
autant je comprends que mes camarades
soient soit vraiment très intéressé et
je comprends très bien mais qu'ils y
sont un minimum de protection parce que
là quelque part le fait de dans le bus
michael tout même s'il ya quand même des
courants d'air malgré tout on est gamin
pop un peu plus entourées donc un peu
plus théoriquement protégés mais deux
ans et vêtements à mes attentes en
matière de découverte de tchernobyl et
du site donc à ce moment là ça suffit
pour les touristes en mal de sensations
fortes le bus fait un détour par ce
qu'on appelle la forêt rousse mais là
pas question de s'arrêter
c'est la zone de forer un puits
contaminés le dosimètre s'affolent nous
sommes au milieu de la forêt rousse
[Musique]
le niveau est de 15 microsieverts par
heure et ce n'est pas dangereux d'amener
des touristes ici la dose pour les gens
qui travaillent sur le réacteur
nucléaire peut monter jusqu'à 100
microsieverts par jour nous nous ne
restons qu'une minute et pendant une
minute on ne reçoit qu'un tout petit peu
les autorités ukrainiennes affirme qu'en
six heures de visite les touristes
recevraient 15 microsieverts maximum
l'équivalent d'une radio dentaire
bientôt une masse inquiétant barrent
l'horizon
nous nous rapprochons du réacteur numéro
4 de tchernobyl
celui qui a explosé en 1986
ne vous éloignez pas du monument rester
près de la statue
s'il vous plaît ne vous approchez pas de
la barrière ne prenez des photos que du
réacteur numéro 4 un son métallique
raisin autour de nous le son des travaux
en cours sur le réacteur
le sarcophage construit à la hâte après
l'accident est aujourd'hui fissurer il
faudra quatre ans pour qu'un nouveau
sarcophage terme et qu'il soit achevé
combien de personnes sont-elles mortes
depuis l'explosion du 26 avril 1986
selon les chiffres officiels environ dix
mille selon les ong
cinq à dix fois plus
ça fait quelque chose ça c'est spécial
de voir là là où peut mener par folie
technologique de l'homme
c'est impressionnant vraiment
cela répond pas j'aurais aimé lui dire
jusqu'à 300 mètres du réacteur cola lui
est toujours focalisé sur son compteur
mais ici la pareille arrive à saturation
ça peut être est conçu pour ça ça a été
construit pour mesurer des doses ça
montre que qu'avec le nucléaire on peut
pas tout prévoir ce second de must
appareils ils n'ont pas prévu que
qu'on irait qu'on ira mesurer ce genre
de choses au pied du monstre d'acier la
radiation est 100 fois supérieures à la
dose naturelle en france
notre guide y guitart chuq accompli la
visite une dizaine de fois par mois a
priori la radioactivité ne semble pas
l'inquiéter faux mythes
pour moi c'est juste mon lieu de travail
et vous savez c'est un lieu de travail
normales pour beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent sur la centrale et ça vous
plaît de travailler ici
est-ce que ça me plaît et mondiaux c'est
mon boulot mais j'aime mon boulot
yuri ne nous en dira pas plus mais les
guides qui travaillent ici savent bien
qu'ils mettent leur santé en danger à
l'extérieur de la zone à 80 kilomètres
de kiev nous avons rencontré un autre
guide
il s'appelle maxime il a 33 ans et comme
tous les guides pour préserver sa santé
il ne travaille que quinze jours par
mois dans la zone irradiée
ça c'est un métier
qui est très risquée si vous ne suivez
pas des règles si vous ne respectez pas
ça peut provoquer les particules
radioactives
contact avec ces particules peut
provoquer les maladies comme les quais
mis à cancer et
beaucoup d'autres choses on est obligé
de passer une fois par an l'examination
médicale à l'hôpital de tchernobyl le
dernier fois au mois j'ai eu de la
chance
j'étais très très clair très très peu ou
pas du tout de radionucléides dans mon
organisme pas du tout la chance voilà ça
se saurait pas toujours cette chance
vous pensez
tout est possible tout peut arriver dans
la vie je sais pas maxime a accepté ce
travail parce qu'en quinze jours
seulement il touche 300 euros c'est
trois fois plus que le salaire mensuel
d'un professeur d'université
c'est pour ça que larissa sa mère a
d'abord soutenu son choix il y a plein
de chômage en ukraine
et quand il a commencé ce travail son
épouse était étudiante dans une école
payante
c'est lui qui payait les cours et en
plus il avait déjà un petit bébé
il était obligé travailler là bas mais
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'ils arrêtent
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils arrêtent
parce qu'au fond de moi je suis très
inquiète
mais d'après ce qu'il nous a confié
maxime n'a pas du tout l'intention
d'arrêter pour le moment dernière partie
de la visite nous voici à pripiat à
trois kilomètres seulement de la
centrale
[Musique]
avant 1986 beaucoup de scientifiques
vivaient dans sept villes soviétiques
modèle et le niveau de vie était
supérieure à la moyenne du pays
[Musique]
la catastrophe nucléaire a figé la cité
dans le temps les 48 mille habitants ont
dû faire leurs valises en deux heures
pour ne jamais revenir
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus qu'une
ville fantôme la végétation s'est
attaqué à l'ossature des bâtiments les
vandales ont fait le reste
[Musique]
dans cette école scènes d'apocalypse
[Applaudissements]
l'accident
il ya beaucoup au lendemain de
l'accident sans doute voilà on voit
prend conscience de l'ampleur du
désastre qui s'est passé ici en voyant
sur d'autres choses
puis décolle on a l'habitude de voir sa
propre nickel alors l'a ravagée c'est
bizarre ça fait bizarre
et on sent un peu belle les jeunes
hommes sont effectivement mal à l'aise
l'ambiance est pesante ça m'intéresse
enfin je suis très heureux d'avoir vu ça
mais c'est le jeu et je pense pas que je
reviendrai donc que je pense après avoir
vu ça on laissera le temps de rentrer
quoi ironie du sort ces masques n'ont en
fait rien à voir avec l'explosion du
réacteur de tchernobyl
nous la prendrons plus tard ils ont été
déballés et abandonner la part des
pillards qui ne s'intéressait qu'aux
métal qu'il contenait
en 1986 les autorités soviétiques n'ont
pas prévenu immédiatement les habitants
des dangers de l'explosion alors pendant
plus d'une journée les enfants sont
venus étudier comme un jour normal avant
d'être évacuée avec les autres habitants
la visite s'achève en traversant la
carcasse d'un parc d'attraction rouillé
le silence a définitivement remplacé le
rire des enfants que sont devenus les 48
mille personnes qui vivaient là combien
ont été irradiés combien sont mortes des
questions sur lesquelles notre guide ne
veut pas s'attarder
vous n'avez pas l'occasion de parler un
peu des victimes dites moi ce que vous
voulez savoir et je vous répondrai
je pense que tout le monde a eu assez
d'information là dessus et puis
l'objectif principal d'une visite de ce
genre c'est avant tout que chacun se
fasse sa propre expérience pour
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé
à la sortie de la zone passage
obligatoire par le détecteur de
radiations ces machines d'un autre âge
sont censés nous dira si le visiteur est
contaminée voyant vert tout va bien
mais il arrive que le voyais en soie
rose ça sonne pour une personne sur 100
ça sonne souvent vers les chaussures ou
sur les semaines alors nous on fait
laver dans l'eau les mains et les
chaussures
je n'ai plus dangereux le plus
dangereuses s'est situé inhalent ça
provoque le cancer et vous contrôler ce
que les touristes sont inhalées non
[Musique]
cette machine ça suffit maxime quitte la
visite plutôt rassuré satisfait surtout
la ville après tu m'aimeras démasquer
tous parce que je me suis laissé porter
par le
mais aymeric lui reste inquiet arrivé à
kiev il se débarrasse de ses chaussures
dans une poubelle
pour le vice secrétaire d'état au
tourisme
c'est une précaution bien inutile s'il
est passé sous le portique de contrôle
il n'y a pas de danger s'il a envie de
jeter ses chaussures
c'est son problème oui mais les experts
français eux conseillent de laver les
chaussures qui ont marché dans la zone
interdite de façon systématique
nos scientifiques en collaboration avec
des scientifiques européens s'estiment
matisson de constante recherche dans la
zone
s'il y avait un danger avec les
chaussures nous le saurions de doper
donc selon les autorités pourtant un
mois seulement après le voyage de nos
cinq france l agence tchernobyl une
terrine forme a suspendu toutes les
entrées dans la zone interdite
le parquet général ukrainien
contesterait les conditions de la visite
du site jusqu'à nouvel ordre
il n'est donc plus possible de passer
ses vacances à tchernobyl